hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
november 30th 2020 what's going on how
are you
uh how you doing i'm [ __ ] snapping
right and left
not in anybody necessarily i am just
things are bothering me
things are bothering me like i just went
out you know because i'm going on the
road here so i went out i got my old
truck so i started up to make sure when
i come back it doesn't have a dead
battery right
so you know i go and i take the tarp off
the thing you don't want to make sure i
lay it out the way i need to lay it out
so it's not a big confusion thing when i
try to go put it back on again
and i i [ __ ] go to put the thing back
on again i'm looking for the hole with
for the antenna and i'm just like you
got to be [ __ ] kidding me what did
this thing do a [ __ ] back flip on me
how the [ __ ] did i [ __ ] this up
flipping out standing up in the back of
the truck hitting my head on a [ __ ]
tree branch looking
[ __ ] thing and uh
turns out i had it the right way i just
i just didn't see where the hole was
just snapping snapping tourette's
the whole [ __ ] thing and um
yeah i don't know i don't know what's
wrong with me every time i think i got
this anger thing
beat like uh i think i just think i have
it beat
and then i just sort of chill and then
just stuff starts building up i need
like an
outlet to get it out of me better than
like oh i'll go play drums or i'll go
work out
i need to be doing something else which
is actually addressing the problem
rather than like well maybe i'll just do
some fun stuff and then i won't be like
[ __ ]
you know flipping out all the time but
uh anyway
whatever i'll go on the road and i'll
[ __ ] i'll try meditating again even
though my [ __ ] ears ring louder than
they ever did because of this
[ __ ] tentaness how the [ __ ] you're
supposed to say
tinnettis tinnitus however the [ __ ] you
say it um
but uh so anyway how'd you guys enjoy
your football sunday did your team win
like mine
can anybody figure out the [ __ ] nfc
west i certainly can't you would have
thought that the [ __ ] rams i mean the
uh yeah the rams would beat the uh
you know the overly injured i would say
49ers and then they turn around they
[ __ ] blow it you know i had a good
feeling about the jets today
did they hang on and win i know they
were doing all right in the first
quarter i'm sure
buff uh not buffalo miami came back and
beat him they got a great defense what i
did was basically i watched
my new england patriots beat a great um
um um i'm um arizona cardinal t uh
kylo murray was a little bit hurt and uh
jesus christ
i never seen two teams commit more
goddamn penalties in my life
they kept throwing the flag on the
patriots and be like jesus [ __ ]
christ what did they bet the cardinals
and every time they showed the clip it'd
be like
all right that was a hold all right that
was you know that was interference
the only one there was only two calls
that i didn't like
was the uh the blind side block when we
returned that punt
and was it a kick off i can't remember
for a touchdown
and that really cost us because we only
got a field goal after that
um i didn't understand the logic of it
the guy
he didn't hit him from behind he didn't
even hit him from the side he hit him
from the front
and um i think it's becoming like hockey
was it because he left his feet
i mean it's not like the guy didn't see
him or whatever i don't know and they
both fell down
so i don't know uh there was that one
and then that [ __ ] one when the guy
on the arizona hit cam newton
um he was in bounce
there was nothing wrong with that hit
other than that they just protect the
quarterbacks and that was a personal
foul gave us 15 yards
and set us up it was ty set us up for
the game-winning field goal
here's my question for all you [ __ ]
athletes out there that are into sports
who are into analytics
like how many um i should actually just
say
sports guys who are in football coaches
i would love for you to chime in
anonymously any coach at any level
what you think about analytics because
my whole time growing up it was take the
points take the points
i'm watching the cardinals in the first
half
all right they're they're like what the
[ __ ] was the score at the half
were they down by three i think they
were down by three or something like
that i don't know what the [ __ ] that i
you know what i actually tweeted about
it it was such a [ __ ] bizarre
bizarre play that they they uh what i
would say decision
that they did they let me look it up
here let me go to my account
oh billy freckles account what did i say
all right the arizona cardinals
cardinals just went for it on fourth and
goal
while up by three points right before
the half
ended yeah it was like first and goal
second third
third and goal they didn't get it kick
the field goal go in up by six
god willing right so they go for it on
fourth down
they don't get it and this is what
drives me nuts
nobody in the booth is questioning
analytics
going like am i out of my [ __ ] mind
or is there 30 minutes of football left
and you just forgot going for seven
you just left a gimme [ __ ] field goal
you know nothing's a gaming board it's
about as close as it's gonna be it's
right on the [ __ ] goal line
just kick the [ __ ] field goal and
then the end of the game
cardinals lose by three points now
obviously if they kick the field goal
they
call different plays who knows what the
[ __ ] happens but i've seen
like i don't know when i was a kid if
you did some [ __ ] like that you got
fired they were all over you i mean
christ the guy's going for it fourth to
go in the second quarter
somebody get the guy a watch now it's
like
i don't know everybody grew up on video
games is that what it is so you just go
for it all the [ __ ] time
oh by the way by the way there was a
lady
who went out and kicked the [ __ ] ball
do you know how bad i was wishing that
person took the ball back and she had to
[ __ ] tackle him
now what does he have to do what is the
woke um
kick off punt return or do in that
situation it's like
i want to run this person over they are
on the other team
but it's a woman and i've been treated
you taught that you don't hit women
and uh you know but i also want to win
the [ __ ] game
and i want to treat her equally because
if there was a [ __ ] little fella in
that suit i'd run right the [ __ ] over
let's look this up here lady
kicks you know they're gonna say woman
kicks
baby jesus christ kicks
i i used the wrong word there lady kicks
off
in
football game all right in football here
we go
sarah fuller became the first woman in a
power five
game on saturday when she delivered the
opening kickoff let's see let's see the
video
is this it uh vanderbilt kicker
first woman to play in
power five the kicker said she was calm
she went out i was really excited to
step on the field and do my thing that's
cool
so my question is is if you [ __ ]
if that dude starts running it back
you know not saying she couldn't [ __ ]
tackle me but you know i'm just a
goddamn comedian here right
well she kind of squib kicked it that's
good
that would be hilarious they're trying
to do this pro woman thing and then she
ends up getting run over and gets
knocked out
you know i mean did he have to
stiff-arm her that hard then they'd go
into that poor kid's twitter history and
try to find something where he trashes
women anywhere
he's been aggressive online since 2008
and a half
then all of a sudden he's in [ __ ]
trouble
um anyways how about your buffalo bills
they just
keep rolling a lot
they just keep rolling along these guys
you know the charges i don't know they
don't know they're young they're very
talented they don't know how to win yet
and the bills
handle them pretty goddamn easily i
heard they played a little sloppy today
27-17 uh looks like they're gonna run
away with the division
oh jesus i had the jets i had the jets
today i'm such a [ __ ] idiot they went
up three nothing i just had this feeling
like it's a division rivalry
in the back of my head that's going
dolphin's got a great defense nah [ __ ]
it [ __ ] it
sam darnell is he's due man he's [ __ ]
due
he's gonna go out there he's gonna make
such [ __ ]
didn't happen didn't happen panthers
[ __ ] blew it they were up against the
vikings
walking all over them and all of a
sudden they came back and then that was
that for that right
browns hang on for the jaguars i
actually want a game i did touch the end
of i got the end of the uh
the uh chiefs first the uh the
buccaneers
and uh i love how much [ __ ] weight
they keep putting all this patrick loves
he wants to be
two and two rather than one and three
against these gates brady on the [ __ ]
buccaneers yet
young [ __ ] relax relax
and he ends up throwing for a first down
to ice the game and they go
oh looks like the student became the
teacher it's like oh i didn't realize
tom didn't know how to do that anymore
it's like he's on he's on the bench
right now
defense is out there he's not covering
the [ __ ] wide receiver
it's like this whole [ __ ] season has
just been about
i mean i'm overly sensitive as a pats
fan so you can take all of this with a
giant grain of salt you can shove it up
your ass but i swear to god
it's all been about wanting to say tom
brady's over
wanting to say bill belichick isn't
wasn't the reason they just keep trying
to [ __ ] [ __ ] on these guys and
but i'm just i just have to understand
that they're just doing that because
they [ __ ]
they trounce people for 20 [ __ ] years
that's gonna happen
um anyway
so who's going on who's that tonight
tomorrow's seahawks one of my favorite
teams to watch
versus the eagles and outside the bears
and the packers the classic matchup but
level that game's gonna be boring as
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bears i swear to god they just
they just bore the [ __ ] out of me
i don't know what it is it's [ __ ]
jesus christ
i'm not excited see uh seahawks eagles
is gonna be fun
the eagles will [ __ ] up seahawks will
make some amazing plays and then eagle
fans will get mad so i mean there's your
entertainment right there
i would think um i will be rooting for
the eagles ah i don't know
i don't know i like seattle somehow all
of a sudden i become a [ __ ] seahawk
fan
um so anyway we you know hilarious the
[ __ ] washington redskins are in first
place
i'm sorry oh it's jesus christ the the
team from washington
now am i in trouble because i said the
name that they were called for [ __ ]
my whole life
up until a month ago two months ago
three months ago i don't know
um it'll be great if they actually
[ __ ] won
if they win the super bowl the team from
washington
wins the super bowl well i was going to
say then it'd be like uh
because you finally addressed the fact
that your name was [ __ ] up that the
football gods forgave you but it's like
wait they they won three super bowls
beforehand look at that [ __ ]
cheeseburger
sorry i got a uh i got the tv on in the
background
it never looks like that i know people
have joked about that a million times
but jesus christ that was a pristine
looking burger
um did you guys watch the fight this
weekend do you watch roy jones versus
mike tyson um
i was very happy with that and very
satisfied
with uh you know dropping the money on
that
i thought it was great that i looked
like mike in the end was going easy
on roy jones like he was sort of
throwing combinations to his chest
where you know he could have gone
upstairs and he didn't i don't i don't
want to see a 51 year old guy get his
[ __ ] brain knocked around again
um i thought you know mike came in in
great shape
and for an exhibition which is what it
was billed as
i was more than satisfied i felt really
bad for nate robinson the way
every [ __ ] loser out there is now
jumping on
him like they would have knocked that
kid out or that they even have the balls
to get into a ring
um good on him for having the balls you
know
go in there he went down swinging and
all that [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] basketball
player
you know is he supposed to [ __ ] be
great at everything
and that could literally happen anybody
and just the fact that how immediately
there were all of these
memes um
human beings are just they're just
[ __ ] [ __ ] they really are
that so many of them are just waiting
for someone to try something and not do
well so they can be like
[ __ ] you you know unreal unreal
uh nothing but respect for nate and then
that i got to give a shout out to the
kid who uh
[ __ ] knocked him out i guess he's
that youtube kid who was out there
you know i guess
he was when in when they were [ __ ]
rioting in stores and [ __ ]
you know with the white kids
i don't know i don't i didn't pay
attention to that [ __ ] i believe he was
one of the people there
but uh i gotta tell you something man
for a [ __ ] you know youtube
star he was very impressive
i was very impressed i mean granted he
was fighting a [ __ ] basketball player
but i mean you know that guy would kick
the [ __ ] out of me
they both would so i i got i got no
problem with either one of them and i i
think uh
people are being too hard on nate
robinson he really is they really are
um but anyway let's uh
let's talk about some happier [ __ ] than
that um so my latest
jones this is why i don't go out and buy
cars
is because every month i fall in love
with another one
you know it's like why would you get
married
if every five seconds you just want to
bang something else you gotta wait till
you're done with that then you can get
[ __ ] married right is that how it
works i don't know
but uh so i was i still love the 67
cadillac el dorado but right now i am
jonesing for a [ __ ]
1886 that generation full-size ford
bronco
blue and white i just [ __ ] i love
that and
uh i was looking i was what the [ __ ]
i found this youtube video this guy had
one they said it was mint
you know ice cold air conditioning
doesn't link a leak or any of that
[ __ ] um
ah [ __ ] i love that truck i wanted that
thing so goddamn bad and when they
changed the front end and 87 to those
[ __ ] aerodynamic headlights i don't
think i ever got over that
they fixed it in the early 90s but that
first generation of uh
aerodynamic trucks like i just thought
the fords were ugly as [ __ ] and the
first
chevy ones i was like what in the [ __ ]
is that with the tiny headlights
tiny headlights now they make sense and
i look them actually think it's
it looks cool a bunny of mine went to
high school who's no longer here with us
his dad had one uh the step side version
of it with the big tires and everything
and it was a [ __ ]
badass looking truck it just took me a
minute but those fords i never got used
to those
but then the uh the oj version i like
that one
um that next generation of them so i've
been looking at those
um toying with the idea
like what if i get rid of my car because
i'm not gonna be that guy
that just has like you know three or
four cars i can't be that guy
you know what i mean i have too many
other [ __ ] like i have like a big
thing with the garage
i judge people harshly by their garage i
am a big believer that your garage
should only have garage [ __ ] in it you
should have and you should be able to
eat off the floor it should be just as
clean as the [ __ ] house
and this [ __ ] [ __ ] that
everything that you don't that you
shouldn't have bought but you did buy
and you can't find somebody to buy it or
bring yourself to throw it out
ends up in the [ __ ] garage is uh
that's not a life i want to live
you know
i don't know how to explain it it's just
like
i always feel like if you work for a
moving company
all right and you're assessing the job i
always feel like they do the walkthrough
of the house and the two places they
take a deep breath as if there's a
basement
or the garage right before they [ __ ]
open the garage door it's just like a
okay here we go we're gonna need an
extra [ __ ] truck and three more guys
um please no holders no holders no
holders
so um that's like another reason i don't
have
i don't i don't have the [ __ ] room uh
i told you guys half of my garage
i turned into like a drum room which by
the [ __ ] way
um i can now jam to good times bad times
and uh i can do the three in a row with
that lick
and i can i one time did
you know the longer version of that same
lift the 16th note triplet
lick i can get through uh most of it
then it falls apart a little bit but
like it's such a weird thing where up to
a certain temple you're
sort of playing it more as opposed to
sliding
and i kind of was hitting a wall at like
80 or 85 bpms
until i finally just said [ __ ] it and i
started playing along to the song
and then just i just my drum teacher
said what
instead of playing to play all three
just try to get one and then one became
two and then what i did was i just
started playing to the song and rather
doing doing that classic
uh sort of thing i i would play the
first one skip the middle one
and then play two in a row around the uh
the backbeat on
beat number four and uh
just doing that for like a week all of a
sudden
i could get like three in a row sorry i
got like into justin that's why
i was speaking like this with pauses um
sorry
um so um
yeah all of a sudden i just sort of
added that to my arsenal because what
what
killed me was when i would watch people
do it
you know there's a zillion people that
can do it uh play that song
there's only one guy that could come up
with that whole [ __ ] drum beat though
but everybody else has sort of broken it
down when i watched these kids playing
at
kids you know they were just sliding up
the foot pedal
and i was just like i just have to get
that muscle memory down and it's
actually
easier than
it sounds it sounds like it just blew my
mind it's just i just i just think it
was just something i just never had the
time for because i do all these other
jobs so now i'm like right there and of
course now i'm gonna go on a [ __ ]
eight nine day tour boohoo i have to
tell jokes for a [ __ ] living
in the great state of texas that also
gets a ton of [ __ ]
um so um anyway speaking of that the
texas tour
texas tour look out i'm coming for you
gonna go to dallas first big d
everything's bigger the botox the
[ __ ] fake titties
and the sh cow [ __ ] under my boot
um that is all
going down what the [ __ ] richmond upsets
number 10 kentucky
first win versus an ap top 10 team what
college hoops has begun he's a primetime
player baby
uh let's go to my website i never do
this [ __ ] bill burr
i wonder if you get put on like a watch
list if you go to your own if you google
yourself
as somebody that could potentially turn
into a manchurian candidate the man
googles himself this is the exact kind
of self-involved person
who won't care what we put in the water
supply all right
i am going to be november 30th i'm at
the a t
performing ah santa
uh annette strauss square is
uh in dallas texas
um i got two shows on the 30th
two shows on the first and two shows on
the second i
love spending a couple two three days in
a city
big d big d right here big d this is
where they killed john kennedy right you
go down you check it all out go over
here get yourself some barbecue
this is right where uh uh who's the guy
that said shot kennedy what the [ __ ]
his name i thought f lee bailey that's a
lawyer now lit right right where you're
sitting
eating that pulled pork sandwich
uh lee harvey oswald allegedly
changed his socks before he went up to
the book depository
which we will be seeing at the end of
this tour so you know
make sure you eat up your pulled pork
sandwiches try not to get any little rub
on your shirt make sure you don't have
sticky fingers because this
is a historical sack that we are
bringing you to
i'm up for doing that you know socially
distancing
um dealey plaza
i'm gonna take a tour of love field if i
can
i heard you can take a tour of that
airport i kind of i love old airports
small airports and all of that [ __ ] i'm
gonna have a great time and then after
that oh [ __ ]
i thought i i ended in austin turns out
i go there next
i go to austin texas i go from big d i
can't believe they took the election
away from donald trump i am so sad the
other day i had to shoot a pig just to
get it just to make me stop thinking
about it
then i'm going to go down to austin
texas where they're going to be like oh
my god [ __ ]
god we got a warmonger we did it you
guys i must listen to those
[ __ ] stupid-ass white kids with their
tie-dyes and their [ __ ] dreadlocks
all those dirty white kids um
i gotta listen to that [ __ ] and then i
end up in uh
houston houston texas where i got to
leave a pair of tickets for joel olsteen
one of the biggest acts in show business
mad respect for that guy joel olsteen
that
he bought anybody can go to not anybody
but you know
you work hard enough you get lucky you
get a catchphrase you know
you don't take your dick out at work
maybe someday eventually you can perform
in an arena
or or
or you can get as big as joel olsen
and you can buy the arena that the
houston rockets used to play in
and you can go up and you can just you
you never have to go on the road
the crowd comes to you and sunday
after sunday after sunday this guy
is selling like 13 000 you ever see like
how billy joel
billy [ __ ] joel does like a week or a
weekend or something like that
every month at madison square garden and
he sells it out
every [ __ ] time i mean that is
incredible
that is incredible okay joel olstein
right
he does all four sundays every month 52
[ __ ] sundays a year right plus
christmas and easter
it's a couple other days in there uh
loincloth day whatever the [ __ ] some
jesus [ __ ] right flag day one is what is
it a passover that's jewish
is there an extra one in there there's
the ash wednesday there's
easter the good friday match right i
don't remember
um crazy level respect for that guy
it'd be great he'd come out to the show
he could pray for me
and uh so i'm doing two nights in
houston
oh that's great two nights in houston no
yes two nights in houston uh december
sixth and seventh
and then i got two nights in austin
texas and i got
three nights in dallas
wait no i got one two three oh four
nights four nights in dallas look at
dallas hooking me up
[ __ ] love going to dallas i used to
go to uh
the improv down there and vinnie paul
used to come out
late great vinny paul would come down to
the shows at the improv
and then i remember the next time i came
to dallas he had moved to vegas
and he was supposed to come out to my
show uh next time i played out there and
then he passed away and then it's sad
[Music]
um but i did get to talk to him
and get to know him a little bit and i
talked to him about uh
the drummers that he liked and i loved
that he loved alex van halen and thought
that he was underrated that really made
my day oh speaking of that
eddie van halen's son wolfgang has a new
song out
and um it's a [ __ ] solid song i
really liked it and then in the end
he plays like the sweetest voicemail
like message from his dad
eddie ever which is the exact kind of
dad that i want to be and the exact kind
of relationship i want to have with my
kids
someday when they're all grown up um
and people were asking hey when he left
that message this
goes to show you what kind of a dad
eddie van halen was
people were going was it your birthday
did you graduate
high school you know did did you you
know
save somebody from drowning and he was
like no that was just a regular
voicemail that's just the kind of dad he
was
um so i don't know evidently playing
guitar wasn't the only thing that eddie
van halen just
seemed to understand i mean that's
really amazing so you should check it
out of course let me let me get the name
of it now that i've
hyped it up here hang on hang on let me
set this down here
wolf gang van halen
distance i believe is the song all right
yeah wolfgang van halen mammoth
uh distance what i believe mammoth was
wasn't
at one point one of the first names for
the uh
van halen i believe and then david lee
was the guy going you guys should call
it van halen
am i crazy am i babbling i probably am
all right let's um
thank you to everybody in the great
state of texas
um that if that has uh you know
gone out and bought tickets um i cannot
[ __ ] wait to do these shows i've been
having some of the best shows in my
career
out here in la uh something happened
when i did those chapelle show gigs
chappelle show the dave chappelle uh
summer camp gigs
where i went out there and i don't know
there was no cameras
it just felt like doing the way stand-up
was before
all of these these crazy women tried to
destroy it
i'm not saying women are crazy but they
were crazy people who happen to be women
and really weren't that funny
started telling comics what they should
[ __ ] do and
and this went back to it reminded me of
doing stand-up
before the internet where it was just
like
whatever happened happened in that room
and that was it and it was a special
thing
and the show was over and then that was
[ __ ] it
there was no i and i i hadn't realized
how much over the last five years that
as i was doing my
act i was like sort of metaphorically
looking over my shoulder
and and hating that i was doing it but i
couldn't get that thought out of my head
like is
you know is this gonna offend
is somebody gonna hey you know
i don't know and then the worst thing
ever watching other comedians attack
other [ __ ] comedians
is just i don't know that is just became
the red scare
where [ __ ] actors were ratting out
other actors just [ __ ]
it was just [ __ ] horrible so
hopefully that's over but um
anyway so thanks to dave chappelle for
those three days of gigs
it it [ __ ] cleared my mind and i've
been doing stand-up that way
ever since and uh i've been having more
goddamn fun
saying crazy [ __ ] and just having a good
time so
uh what better place to go out and go
try some new [ __ ]
than texas um i mean texas even if
you're bombed the state's so big it
takes three days for the whole state to
know what happened by then you left
uh what about the internet ah that's
some liberal [ __ ]
um you get me a [ __ ] messenger crows
all right me undies i'm gonna do a
little advertising here everybody oh
look who it is what it did did me undies
me undies [ __ ]
[ __ ] in your pants on thanksgiving
weekend oh god me undies be
undies why did i go into that way
nothing [ __ ] rhymes with that
you know why cause but the beginning of
the song i was trying to remember did i
already talk about thanksgiving and yes
i did it with my lovely
wife the lovely knee i forgot so let me
try it again all right take two
everybody all right
yeah am i billy you need a break no i'm
fine just roll the [ __ ] tape
all right do me undies me undies rooting
for my football team
do me undies the undies when the rest
away is the dream
and buffalo loses so everyone cries
they have some chicken wings including
some thighs cause they lose again and
my pets go on to knock off the [ __ ]
chiefs and the seahawks and we're number
seven
hey i can dream big all right all right
me undies everybody the holidays
dooby dooby doo can be the most
stressful time of the year
if only there were some bearded man with
a bottomless bag of
everything you need to cross off that
list thankfully our friends at meundies
have the next best festive thing
me undies curated a list of the stuff
your friends really want this year so
yep
can soften the holiday stress what's the
saying
work softer not harder
is that a saying i've never heard of
that uh their micro modal model
is not only super soft but breathable
light and impossibly cozy ah [ __ ] i was
gonna name my
next special that bill burr and possibly
cozy
um it's everything you need to have a
stress-free
and comfortable holiday give someone me
time
oh gift some me time sorry with me
undies sustainable soft
undies pj sets slippers
and more uh different prints color
styles whatever the [ __ ] you need they
got it you can also gift a membership
with a meundies gift card
their membership is a subscription that
sends new pairs right to their doors let
me tell you something nothing impresses
the ladies
like having a nicey you know everybody
can flash your [ __ ]
platinum uh american express card when
you bust out the [ __ ] my aunt my
me undies [ __ ] what is it called the
me undies uh gift card i'll forget it
they're like this guy likes to snuggle
um
[Music]
um oh speaking of women huh how'd you
guys do this year wednesday before
thanksgiving that's always the chance to
go
right all the wrongs go back and cross
the t's and dot the eyes ladies and
gentlemen
go back and find the one that slipped
away after a couple of bud lights at the
local tavern there
oh but not this year the old covid
cockblock kicked in all right their
membership is a subscription that sends
new pairs right to the door so they
never have to run out of
undies again with site-wide savings and
exclusive sales they automatically
pay less for well well for well
everything i love when they even try to
make it conversational so i won't [ __ ]
it up and then i still do uh meundies
has a great offer for my listeners
my listeners nobody well probably other
people but i'm gonna act like it's just
me
for the first time for first-time
purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping me undies also has
their problem-free philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it
no caveats no questions no [ __ ] uh
to get to get your 15 off your first
order and free shipping go to
meundies.com that's me undies
m-e-u-n-d-i-e-s dot com slash burr
b-u-r-r
oh look who it is everybody
[Music]
by zan how you doing hey
that's it pretty go my bookie everybody
get the [ __ ] out of here
my bookies back i hope you guys feasted
on my bookie turkey day free play
that allowed users to grab themself a
risk-free bet
up to 250 dollars
you can buy a used grandfather clock for
that kind of money
it was basically a free shot at trying
to double your money
if you didn't get in on that what are
you doing
no but seriously now is the time to get
some skin in the game with my boogie
where odds boost
lightning deals and free bets await all
season
long and with the nfl playoffs right
around the corner playoffs
we know who the teams are we know what
they're capable of
and it's not difficult to find some
value in the lines
whether you're a first-time customer or
have been playing with my bookie for
years
uh that sounded a little creepy playing
with my bookie for years uh this is
there is no shortage of value to be
found in the thousands of game
game lines unique prop bets and contests
that they offer every week
sign up or get reloaded today find an
edge
make your bet and get paid they also
boost a fully fledged casino platform
giving you access to all the classic
table slot and card games you'd expect
to find at your local spot
and the best part is at my booking the
doors never close so you can continue to
build your bankroll
even after the stadium lights have gone
out i'm picturing you under your
comforter while your wife's sleeping
it's glowing what are you doing under
there oh reading come on you sex
uh make the right play and sign up today
at my bookie and when you do
use the promo code burp b-u-r-r to get
your deposit matched halfway
all the way up to a thousand bucks the
terms are simple just like you
um
[Laughter]
there's nothing smart about this uh you
put in 200 bucks they'll match you with
another 100 bucks in your account
if you were already planning to bet this
season this is free betting money
it's winning season at my bookie out of
what you doing
so come join in on the fun and win some
cash while you're at it
all right what do we got we got we got
two more here oh look who it is
everybody look who it is come on
in come on in and grab a seat and sit
down it's all zip
[Music]
you know businesses have had to be
flexible this year just like the [ __ ]
up the street
from working remotely to pivoting their
business models for long-term survival
and growth
that's what she said uh share some of
your own examples
on the following restaurants are moving
their dining outdoors and adding takeout
and catering
oh i show up without a mask and be like
i should be able to eat that hot dog
inside
um some consumers package
uh goods companies have shipped to focus
more on surface cleaners or personal
hygiene
products major retailers are now selling
face masks
um am i nuts those cloth ones never seem
to fit your [ __ ] face they're never
quite big enough
i mean i know i got a big squash here
people but jesus christ and then you
throw him in the wash one time
it comes out he's like was this built
for a [ __ ] toddler
um all right if you're in charge
of hiring for your business these pivots
have made your job even more
more challenging sorry especially if you
have to hire for brand new roles
thankfully there's one place you can
always count on to make hiring faster
and easier it's all zip
dot com when you post the job on zip
it gets sent to over 100 top job boards
with one clip
click then ziprecruiter's powerful
technology finds people with the right
skills and experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply it's
no wonder four to five
employees who post on zip yeah
get a quality candidate within the first
day see for yourself right now
you can try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
that's ziprecruited.com spell it out
zip
r-e-c-r-u-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
take hiring off your plate so you can
focus on growing your business
go to zip
dot com slash burp all right last one
everybody
oh look who it is look who it is
it's uh helix everybody helix i finally
got this the pronunciation down helix
not helix helix uh look look i know some
of you are sleeping on
saggy old mattresses at night and you
deserve better than that
give yourself an upgrade with helix
sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from soft
medium and firm just take their quick
two-minute quiz online
and they'll match you with the mattress
that's perfect for your body type and
sleep preferences
my friends love their helix mattresses
the best part
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but trust me you will
gross uh helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
all right then all righty
let's get into the questions for the
week
all right what do we got here what are
we looking at how much time have i done
here
what do i got left 39 minutes jesus
christ time is flying when you're
screaming the f word
um weight loss hey
hey bill bognish whatever the [ __ ] that
means
uh i just want to say that i started
working on my weight after seeing your
bit
on the walk your way out special about
fat [ __ ]
not only was it super funny but it was
also became motivational
i started at 400 pounds jesus christ you
were a big dude
and i've managed to lose over 150 pounds
that's [ __ ] amazing
i started at a 56 waistline
and i got it down to a 38 and i am
certain to be a 36 by my birthday and a
34 by spring
i hope you see this thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself dude that's [ __ ] awesome
because you know what i put on a few
i put on a few you know i had a few
stressful things i got on the other side
of it and then uh you know
i started eating like an ass you know
what it was i made pumpkin bread for um
for halloween all right because i like
the holidays
i like getting together with people and
just being thankful
and uh you know i ate most of it
you know i usually make a couple of
loafs and then i hand them out to people
but with this whole [ __ ] pandemic
[ __ ] you know i just don't see as many
people so
instead of having one loaf we had two my
family was sick of it after the first
loaf and i sort of plowed through the
second one
and i just haven't recovered you know i
just started eating sweets and [ __ ] i've
just been [ __ ] up so
i'm gonna try when i'm in texas i'm
gonna bring
gloves in a [ __ ] mask and i'll see if
they have a hotel gym because i need a
an elliptical like you read about now i
would go on a hike in dallas but as far
as i know
other than that grassy knoll that they
have downtown it's all pretty much flat
land so
can you guys let me know where's a good
place to go for a hike where i can be
outside
you know amongst the locals not wearing
masks
because the virus is afraid of texas
tell me where i can go dude that's
[ __ ] awesome or or ma'am whoever did
it
god bless you dude or ma'am
person they whatever i'm supposed to say
that's [ __ ] great
all right name names please
dear billy for the people thank you for
all your great work i'll cut right to it
you've consistently been saying listen
to the scientists
the problem is is you don't ever cite
any scientist by name oh the cdc i say
it all the time
the center for disease control also you
blame the few people who don't wear
masks for locking down the whole economy
yes you did it's not few people it's
literally half the [ __ ] population
and it's going on out here i like how he
goes yes you did like i said no i didn't
yeah i am blaming them i'm 100 blaming
them because now they're all gonna
[ __ ] turn around and blame the
government like
you were supposed to solve this while i
didn't hold up my end of the bargain
where uh there was never going to be
less than one percent
infected um how do you know that now
where are you getting your stats from
how are you still just going along
saying listen to the scientists
when there's tons of doctors who are
saying this isn't going away
yet it gets to the why why
first of all they're gonna have like a
uh some sort of shot that they can give
you by january
um but this is what i love is you're not
a doctor and i'm not a doctor and i'm
literally listening
to the center for disease control
this is what they do there's tons of
doctors there's a lot of doctors that
you know who are like [ __ ] you know
dentists and proctologists and they'll
have a [ __ ] opinion
on how to control a virus but this is
not their field
okay if somebody just paints cars
you don't want to rebuild your engine
that's not what this person does
so i would i would then you gotta you
gotta really this is actually a great
email
because you have to be able to sift
through all this well what kind of
doctor is this person
okay all i can go by is what the people
that that are
been put in place and been trained to
fight something like this
are saying i'm not going to listen to a
podcast listener
who goes on the internet and finds air
quote doctors
you know else hired a scientist jim
irsay to invest in new england patriots
turns out he wasn't even a scientist so
you really got to be careful anyways
tons of exclamation po all encounter
doctors are saying that early detection
facilities
uh should not be something people are
scared of um
celebrity brats i love how they always
blame celebrities for [ __ ]
as opposed to what all the mature
non-famous people
on the internet how nice you guys all
are get the [ __ ] out of here
i am so sick of the [ __ ] the the the
uh
the building up of joe's six-pack oh you
mean that [ __ ] racist [ __ ]
um yeah he puts his pants on one leg at
a time yeah on the way to his [ __ ]
clan meeting
the [ __ ] out of here all right celebrity
brats and hypocritical politicians
saying don't gather with your family for
thanksgiving they can
[ __ ] off
this is just this is one of the most
epicly selfish [ __ ] times
uh listening to these elitists with
absolutely no concern for real people
is a sickness um if you're just gonna
gather and not listen to these people
don't you just have no concern for real
people
and who are you to say who's real
because somebody has a tv show means
they're not real
because somebody has a little bit of
money
they're not real anymore and yes they
are
elite you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about you [ __ ] dope
you [ __ ] national inquirer reading
[ __ ] mouth breathing dope go get mad
at the guy on my two dads you dumb
[ __ ] jesus christ you're like somebody
who like [ __ ]
probably thinks there's a difference
between a republican and a [ __ ]
democrat right
the [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] all right let's
let's do this do the usual thing let's
just make fun of the obvious when you
watch football let me guess you just
blame the quarterback right
um you [ __ ] ball washer um watcher
sorry um
and yes they are elite they have money a
voice and unconditional support
from droning mouth breathers oh god dude
are you [ __ ] you don't even know what
you're talking about
let me go to my twitter feed right now
and just read you all the hate that i
get you should see
they posted something on on my
all things comedy posted something hey
you know his bill at the troubadour
and somebody just like like took the
time to write three paragraphs about how
unfunny i am
how ever since i got married i'm not
funny and i have kids i'm not funny
anymore i don't have time to watch game
just
trashed me trash me
most of my conversations i have with
people in this business
is right after they put something out
everybody says the same thing
do not go online don't go online
you did a good job don't read what those
people have to say it is [ __ ] brutal
but of course you know it's just you
know we're all hanging out
courtside at a lakers game right
drinking baby blood is that what we're
doing
um anyways people pile on who'd have
thought i'd ever stick up for hollywood
um people pile on and agree with them
because they feel part of a group ah
dude you know what i i have to respect
your broad brush
i paint with one all the time and you
were doing a great job with this canvas
stop blindly saying listen to scientists
[ __ ] you
listen to scientists without pointing
out the cdc
in a direction besides the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] cdc
what's wrong with the center for disease
control
which is just an extension of the
financial slash political system
making the decision okay so what am i
supposed to do go into the corporate
world
with that [ __ ] [ __ ] that they put out
what the [ __ ] uh that killed prince and
everybody else
those those people hey here's a cure for
a headache if you have suicidal thoughts
diarrhea and you accidentally stab your
cat
contact your local physician is that the
scientists i'm supposed to listen to
anyways just like the presidents with no
military experience making war decisions
the cdc has lawyers making decisions for
them for the love of god please restore
a healthy amount of questioning
the official narrative to your process
here yeah you know what i should do
i should listen to people who drive
around in trucks saying [ __ ] your
feelings i'm not wearing a mask
that's who i'm supposed to listen to
obviously this is a new disease
this is the thing if everybody just
[ __ ] wore their goddamn mask and did
what the cdc told you to [ __ ] do
we all could have rode this [ __ ]
thing out would not have had second
third and fourth [ __ ] waves and now
we just gotta wait for these guys to
come up with some sort of cure
or some or i don't know what but
to just to turn a blind eye to people
who just
openly just disregarded all of that [ __ ]
right up to that dumb orange-headed
[ __ ] [ __ ]
who caused an outbreak in the [ __ ]
white house from not listening to the
cdc
i mean i just don't know how i mean
listen i'm not excited about joe biden
i'm really not but at least the [ __ ]
idiot's wearing a mask over his face
lift who gets a facelift at 80.
it worked it worked he got 71 million
point two votes um masks work
lockdowns don't all right this is the
broad brush crew here
hey bill 21 year old london stoner
uh stoner heir ghee
geezer call me a giza right saw you in
london at the royal albert hall it was
[ __ ] hilarious mate
when you called bill clinton the first
male first lady almost shot myself
okay i agree with you completely about
wearing masks i wear one i also
encourage people to do
to too well that's good however i do not
think that people not wearing them is
the reason for our government
is a is the reason our governments have
decided
to lock down for a second time
i'm not sure what's going on uh
in the whole of america but here we've
gone back into national lockdown
uh now that we know the average age of
death of corona is above the average age
of death
okay now where did you get that stat i'm
just supposed to believe that
because some 21 year old kid told me
this [ __ ] this is what gets crazy
uh it really doesn't make sense to
destroy our economies
for a second time all right let me ask
you this like
if people just did what they said to do
i don't think that they have to lock it
down again although i do love a
conspiracy
theory so if you're telling me that
the ponzi schemes that all the
uh the the strongest currencies i mean i
don't know anything about those i just
know ours
we've been off you know we just print
money over here i don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on
you hand it to somebody and then they
give you some goods and you go all right
i guess it still works right that's
what's going on over here now in my
heart of hearts they might use this
as a way to i don't know i don't know do
what
i have no [ __ ] idea i don't know how
to reset a [ __ ]
economy i don't know how you would do
that but um
i do know this is like people have been
astoundingly
[ __ ] selfish during all of this [ __ ]
and um including people i know like
oh god i hate these [ __ ] masks i mean
i just can't believe like what [ __ ]
[ __ ] people are you just can't put on
a [ __ ] mask
like like that's that's your biggest
hardship
you know and then you get [ __ ] pissed
when they're gonna lock it down again
because there's another [ __ ] breakout
and
and all you see is that the government's
a bunch of [ __ ] idiots
and greedy sons of [ __ ] and all that
i would never argue that but you know
you also have to come around
do you remember earlier i'm gonna pat
myself in the back here
all right why not um
i said there was two bad calls in that
patriots game and one
went against us and the other one helped
us out
okay and i really think if you're gonna
be [ __ ] open-minded about this [ __ ]
you can't just hold um
the government responsible for these
[ __ ] lockdowns
i mean people just going around going
hey i'm young it really doesn't affect
young people i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
going to a party
i'm going to [ __ ] go hang out with 20
other people on jet skis in the middle
of a [ __ ] lake i mean
joe biden won so we're all going to go
run around and have a big liberal party
and [ __ ]
you know not wear masks they they are
just as much to blame how about how
about we do that
how about we just say that um
does that work i don't know jesus christ
did you guys see that [ __ ] f1 crash
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] how did that guy
survive
i mean his car literally looked like it
was sitting on a [ __ ] smoker for 12
hours
um anyways people don't get mad at me
i'm just i don't have any [ __ ]
answers okay this this
podcast was never about getting proper
information okay and like i've always
been
the person sort of going like i think
this is [ __ ] i think that is
[ __ ] until
it came time for this thing this was
just a a
thing that just took over everywhere
and um i don't know to say that this is
some big conspiracy to reset the money
then if that is the case
then all countries would be on board
is that how it would work i mean go
ahead tell me i'm i'm up for it anyways
let's just continue here
anyways now that um local businesses are
closing everywhere and all i keep seeing
is more mcdonald's and
kfc advertisement
uh costa and [ __ ] starbucks i reckon
these [ __ ]
are gonna have gone
and paid for another lockdown to kill
all the mon paw
shops off well i think you're giving
starbucks
and mcdonald's a little bit too much
credit for the amount of power that they
have
um i mean i'm open to a conspiracy
theory as what to why they would lock
it down again but like you know listen
if you're wearing a [ __ ] mask and
you're doing what they're saying and
you're still getting [ __ ] i'll listen
to you complain
but if you're driving around like i
don't give a [ __ ] and i'm i'm living for
myself then i really don't give a [ __ ]
what your opinion is personally
all right all right p.s who's your
favorite british comedian
oh [ __ ]
you know i don't i don't i don't know
that scene well enough
to be honest with you um
because i always seem to go over there
and i just do my show and then i leave
i've never been able i've never even
been in the comedy store
like i don't even know who i don't even
know who's who over there to be honest
with you but i know there's a bunch of
funny people
uh there was one guy that i saw of
course i can't remember his [ __ ] name
now
i had this really long crazy dark bit
that i just thought was absolutely
brilliant there's amazing people in
scotland and
england ireland the whole area over
there
i mean i know like the i know the kings
over there you know
the tommy turnings and that type of [ __ ]
obviously i love all of those guys
um billy conley but as far as like
the newer the kids i have no idea i'm
out of the [ __ ] loop i'm trying to
keep up over here so why don't you send
me some
people and i'll check them out anyways
thanks for the comedy the podcast and
the inspiration god bless boston for
giving us the two best bald podcasters
on the planet
all right sleep sex and other activities
all right hey billy boy um long time
listener and first time writer i
recently heard you talk about
three-year-old episode i recently heard
about your three-year-old episode
regarding sleep sex and i wanted to
write you i don't even remember that
three years ago i i talked about sleeps
what is sleep sex
a couple years ago i found out i too
have that issue
sleep sex you have sex while you're
sleeping when the [ __ ] did i ever say i
had that but i got to look this up i got
to see what the [ __ ] this is first
sleep sex you guys are [ __ ] killing
me the [ __ ] that i search
on my sleep sex one sleep disorder you
might not be familiar with is sleep
slack or sexomia
sexsomnia like sleepwalking is a type of
parasomnia
what in the [ __ ] love of god is this
so you're asleep and you're [ __ ]
something
parasomnia is the result of your brain
being cut between
sleep stages this in-between phase
may make you act like you you're awake
when you're still asleep
oh jesus christ
people with sex omnia experience sleep
related
sexual behavior these behaviors range
from
from masturbation to sexual intercourse
treatment for underlying sleep disorder
or behavioral issues may treat sleep sex
to what in the
[ __ ] symptoms
you're waking up with jizz on the front
of your pajamas you don't know how it
got there
uh sex omnia is a different i don't want
to read about this okay whatever
i i mean obviously i must have been i
was talking about this i never suffered
from this
how do you know bill you were asleep
good point good point look at joe biden
joe biden with the mask on and his c.i.a
[ __ ] aviators
getting ready to [ __ ] go after iran
uh a couple of years ago i found out i
too have that issue and i found out
because
i had started dating my girlfriend and
she would often mention how
great last night was and i'll have no
recollection of what she's talking about
oh my god dude you got like a billy
valentine this is like the nutty
professor
at first i was hesitant to talk about it
but as i became
it became more frequent i started asking
more details
she mentioned i lasted far longer than
usual
and the sex was rougher than average too
but she claims to have enjoyed it
dude you got a demon in you man i think
you might need a priest
uh the the power of price compels you
suck it [ __ ] uh so one day i decided to
admit
to her that i had no recollection of any
of these encounters and such activities
she has mentioned she has mentioned and
didn't know what to tell her about it
at first she did not take me seriously
and simply refuse
but then she came back with some medical
related research and we sat down to talk
about it as it is a legit thing people
go through
suffer from holy [ __ ] and dude post me
too and all of this stuff what in the
[ __ ] what if your girlfriend does that
and you think she's awake and you banged
her
oh my god then what happens then what is
that
all right guys you gotta you gotta bring
a cold bucket of water
in with you into the bedroom in the
middle of the night your girlfriend
reaches over and grab your dick you got
to dump it over her head
and she'll get mad and everything but
you know afterwards if she still wants
to [ __ ] you know that she's awake and
that's really her
all right there you go see you know what
that is you know what that is
huh that is come on play it
uh why won't anything work on this
[ __ ] computer
ah that's there we go somebody you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's it was supposed to do this come
here come on
why won't you work it's time hey
hey that's me and you should bring a
cold bucket of water and dump it over
her head before you [ __ ]
all right um here we go needless to say
i was very
wait i reached out to my to my parents
oh my god you talked to them about that
i inquired them
if i had any sleepwalking issues and
they reluctantly said yes
oh boy oh boy they sounded worried
and asked if something had happened oh
my god
did you walk around with your dick in
your hand while you were still living
with your parents and they never said
anything
oh jesus now that's a tough [ __ ]
i bet they had arguments that comes from
your side of the family how dare you put
that on me
uh i did not tell them because our
religion does not allow pre-marital sex
oh good old religion you know anytime
you want to stop the lines of
communication just bring
just bring in a hardcore religious
person anyway
um i did not tell them because our
religion does not allow premarital sex
or even
sharing the same roof with another
gender to live under
i just expressed that i was curious they
told me of times when i wanted to go
grocery shopping in the middle of my
sleep and a few
other times when i would got up early
got ready for school at 3 a.m
3 a.m and just sat outside the house
waiting for the bus to show up
dude that is [ __ ] frightening
it's not as scary as this [ __ ] dude
from england good lord how about a
little [ __ ]
hair gel he looks like he just walked in
from the outside took off a knitted hat
and decided he was going to address the
whole [ __ ] nation
um anyway they told me
they also mentioned situations as
bizarre as me trying to fly a kite in
the middle of the night
the list goes on some of the sleeve
stuff has been productive
needless to say i was very worried and
decided i would sleep in a
separate bedroom than my girlfriend and
also installed cameras to see if i can
catch myself doing things
sure as hell one day i woke up to find
motion alert
through the night in law and and long
behold
isn't it lo and behold i had caught
myself
trying to cook in the kitchen and
proceeding to eat
there have been other harmless
activities too such as me unlocking and
locking the doors
holy [ __ ] but the ones that bother me
the most
if getting to my girlfriend's bedroom
and of course proceeding to have sex
with her
i have however moved away now wait a
minute is your girlfriend helping you
out with this
because if you're [ __ ] her down as is
as the sleep guy
you know i think you're putting her in a
tough spot here
um i have however moved away to a
different city for work this year and
have managed to avoid this behavior i
don't think this sleep
sex bothers my girlfriend it doesn't
sound like it
it's not like you're getting the job
done uh but other things will likely
drive us apart
but that's a topic for another day
anyway hope you and your family stay
safe and
uninfected thank you for your time yeah
dude i gotta ask you
uh
you know what are the if there's a
follow-up to this like what can people
do if they suffer from this
i mean that's terrifying i can't imagine
if you like do you like sleepwalk like
legit sleepwalk to the point you're
unlocking and unlocking [ __ ]
if you've got an apartment like a couple
floors up i mean
it could be a problem right walk right
off the balcony
or the mock balcony i love when they
have like like the the little [ __ ]
thing like
it looks like a balcony but it isn't you
can't even stand sideways on the [ __ ]
thing it's like what is what is that for
um all right dumb questions for
employees lifeguard
dear mr burr
i've been working and interacting with
the public as a lifeguard
on the beach for the last five years the
first four as my
full-time gig uh since you're on the big
red
chair and staring at the ocean people
look at you as the guy with all the
answers
the beach i work at is a popular tourist
destination and i have heard some pretty
dumb questions from these fat
pale hawaiian shirt-wearing socks and
flip-flops sneakers
on the sand mainlanders but god bless
these [ __ ] because
they can't swim for [ __ ] and provide me
with a great job security
here are my top five all right so you
got new listeners here these are uh
top five you work with the public dumb
questions that people ask you number one
where is the bridge going to go beach
patron asked this while pointing at the
pier
which was being repaired after some
storm damage
mind you appear leasing into the
atlantic ocean oh boy
leasing is that the word uh number two
uh lady walked over from her and her
husband's umbrella to ask me
who trains the dolphins i told her that
the lifeguards get to work early
for their training sessions she turned
to her husband and yelled
honey the lifeguards trained the
dolphins
ah jesus they've been to they must had a
season pass at sea world never been to
the beach
uh number three this one needs no
explanation
uh to do this job do you have to be good
at swimming
jesus christ number four top five dumb
things to ask a life card
um we're from kansas and can't swim good
should we get in jesus christ not past
your cankles lady
this guy's got some jokes here i like
this guy
um this final question is the one i get
most frequently
uh are there any sharks out there answer
only big ones
the looks i get are so priceless
sometimes i actually start laughing
um i'm never off duty and i just and i
must remind the listeners if you're
stuck
in a rip current swim parallel to the
shore before
swimming in and always swim near a
lifeguard
thanks for making my ride to work in
solo
sits on the tower fly by how do i
register to the contrarian party for
next election come to florida when the
virus is out of the air
and you won't get a tan line from your
mask
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself you pasty
bastard um
uh you know that rip the riptide rip
current whatever they call it that
fascinates me
like how [ __ ] frightening that is as
you're getting pulled out into the ocean
you're just supposed to be like oh okay
the ocean seems to want me more than the
land does right now and i'm just gonna
relax do a little side stroke
um the ocean scares the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of me i i
don't go in it i have no plans to go in
it i just
you know i've always maintained if if
there was one lobster
without the rubber bands around its
claws in somebody's pool you'd be like
get that thing the [ __ ] out of there
i'm not going in there people go to the
beach
everything's in there all right
it's it's it's [ __ ] crazy i i i don't
understand why people do that [ __ ] but
you know god bless you
god bless you good luck with that all
right butcher edition greetings from
oklahoma you freckle
face [ __ ] up i'm a meat cutter in a
small town grocery store
that sounds great actually sounds like a
really good job i'm reminded
daily of the failures of our school
system so without further ado
here's the list um i'm a meat cutter and
a small town grocery store
jesus christ dude
like that is you know
another life another life that's the
[ __ ] job i would do
you live in the middle of nowhere and
there's not a lot of traffic
you know you can ride to work with your
arm hanging out the [ __ ] window
you know how to hunt and fish right
i don't know that's very appealing to me
all right number one
all right top five dumb [ __ ] questions
people have asked this poor bastard
see cuts their meat in a small town in
oklahoma
number one is this a chicken
some jackass and sunglasses who must
have been at least 40 years old
didn't know what the whole bird looked
like and needed me to confirm
the label item the labeled item
i thought they taught this [ __ ] on the
farm wheel
oh wow number two is this price right
a common question you would think i once
had a lady complain about the price of
ground beef at a dollar eighty-nine
a pound pretty reasonable price around
here she then proceeded
uh proceeded her grandson had been hit
by a car
and died yesterday and needed a lower
lowered price
how the [ __ ] do you respond to that
well i know i would have said well why
don't you go scrape them off the road
that [ __ ] hamburger meat's free
sorry all right number three uh this
will
sorry number three will this
feed my family well seeing from the
sweat stains on your fat rolls i'm gonna
say no
every time i recommend they pick up more
they say
oh we don't eat that much uh the poor
fat bastard
uh number four is there a manager i can
talk to
uh this one depends on if i've shaved
recently
i can explain something very simple
example
why we're out of stock how to prepare
something in the grocery game
a beard demands respect and if you got a
mustache you're golden
who knew i didn't know that all right
number five uh
can you order this thing no one has ever
heard of
what normally it's some elderly folks
longing for the grocery store from days
gone by
had a gentleman come in and ask you have
the hot links
with the with the colored fella on them
oh boy them mexican ones ain't worth a
dog dick
i got to do the right accent yeah you
got damn damn hot links with the colored
fella on them
damn mexican ones ain't worth the dog
nick
i didn't check but i'm oh this is him i
didn't check but i'm pretty certain
uh they canceled they got canceled along
with the uncle ben and aunt jemima
wow yeah that's old people for you
they know the old songs in the uh the
old society all right casino
security all right dear billy tangerine
ball back
i'm a 24 year old paramedic in eastern
canada first off thank you for the
stupidity every week you're welcome uh
these times have been very stressful on
us
yeah healthcare workers and your dumb
ramblings sure have helped me through a
lot you're welcome
anyways enough jerking you off and let's
get down to brass tacks here before
becoming a medic i worked security in a
casino for three years god bless you
you probably still hear those [ __ ]
what's that
ringing from the slots in your ears uh
here are the top five
stupidest comments or questions
all right what do we got here number
five number five number five
um we kicked out a guy for smoking
inside the casino
where i live smoking inside a building
has been illegal since 2004.
he proceeded to lose his [ __ ] screaming
i thought it was like vegas here
i got to be honest with you i thought
you could smoke in casinos too this
dudes thought it was vegas
rules in the casino because our slogan
was a taste of vegas
oh
[Music]
like okay out of all the ones that
people have written in that's the one i
would have been like yeah i would have
said the same thing can i smoke the
cigar i would ask though
you still have to ask about a cigar
number four there's a popular myth that
casinos pump
oxygen to keep people awake and to keep
them playing
from my experience this is absolute
[ __ ] uh
anyway this one guy was absolutely
convinced that this was true one night
he walks up to me
and said that he found proof that we're
pumping oxygen being bored and looking
for entertainment
i agreed to look for his evidence he
then proceeded to show me the ac
unit oh boy um number three
where's the exit to understand this one
bill you have to know that the security
desk is just
outside of these massive glass doors
that overlooks the parking lot
right on top of those doors is an exit
sign
uh number two uh we once had this
one guy who tried multiple times coming
in with fake ids
when i first interacted with him he gave
me an idea of someone
i used to play hockey with when i was
younger i laughed and told him to cut
the [ __ ] because i knew the guy in the
id
he then proceeded to lose his [ __ ] and
tried to argue with
me that it was his id you don't
understand i know this guy this isn't
you
i laughed he would not let it go until i
offered
to call the cops and have him them
sorted out
jesus degenerate gambler or just like
i got to give it up to that guy for
sticking with the lie uh number one
we were told to kick this one guy out
for using
inappropriate language at one of the
tables
now he didn't just say a good old [ __ ]
[ __ ] the guy
said the n-word multiple times oh my god
when we asked him about it he said it
was all okay because his wife is black
i don't think it works like that he said
jesus christ
[Laughter]
wow anyway hopefully you enjoy these
keeps the laughs coming
and of course go [ __ ] yourself p.s don't
feel bad
i don't know what the [ __ ] a joshua tree
is okay cool
all right i got one for you i'm trying
to think way back in the day when i
worked in a dental office
top five dumb things people said i'll
have to think about the one that always
i used to do a joke about it was this
guy came in
and the dentist was like what's the
problem because i got a toothache and i
was typing oh we'll take a look and then
he goes
doc you know i don't understand it i
mean i brush my teeth almost every day
and my joke of my act was great do you
wipe your ass almost every time you take
a [ __ ]
that was my joke um and it was one of my
first [ __ ] jokes
i figured i'd share it with you all
right that is
the podcast i apologize to the mass guy
questioning my scientist [ __ ] i'm just
so [ __ ] sick of being locked down
myself as well as you guys and i'm so
[ __ ] sick of people getting mad
at stupid [ __ ] like [ __ ] celebrities
it's such a [ __ ]
low-hanging fruit oh really do you
really not want to hear what the
kardashians have to say about the
pandemic of course you don't who gives a
[ __ ]
all right they are diversionary tactics
those are diversionary tactics they just
get mad
at these these [ __ ] idiots
um but at the same token uh
you're not better than they are they're
not better than you and you're not
better than them because i will tell you
right now
i have seen a lot of regular ass [ __ ]
joe six-pack people on
on instagram and the social medias there
who have completely disappeared into
their [ __ ] egos
um it's all [ __ ] ego based man it's
so it's
a crazy [ __ ] time so anyways i listen
to the cdc that's the group of
scientists that i listen to
i'm wearing the [ __ ] mask whatever
the [ __ ] it is that they wanted me to do
and if they come up with some sort of
cure this thing i'll be one of the first
people in line i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
with the side effects sorry i don't care
i don't care all right go ahead [ __ ]
you know make me happy with my robot
replacement all right
i've had 52 wonderful years on this
planet
all right that's the podcast everybody
go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll check in on
you from dallas [ __ ] texas on
thursday